foreign
[Music]
hello everyone and welcome to a super
good Productions congratulations
congratulations
[Music]
what up what up we painted you know what
we painted the fingernails black because
we were in Seattle and Portland and
that's what we do and we're on our
grunge tip dude Runner grunge tip sounds
like an STD but we are on our grunge tip
and uh we're keeping it real you know
what I mean I got my water bottle and uh
I'm drinking Arrowhead Water everyone
always makes fun of me for drinking our
head water
they say that it's not good but I
disagree
um cool God you know don't I don't have
covet you know
I um well first of all let's actually do
this
um we appreciate you guys listening and
actually let let's do this we changed
the name of the thing because cult was
for sure Shadow band let's subscribe
make sure you're subscribed to the
channel on YouTube audio's going fine
YouTube let's make sure you're adding to
the uh you're you're adding the
algorithm drop down a comment subscribe
hit that Bell notification actually if
you hit the Bell notification it would
really help uh because that's what we
want to do here at congratulations we
need to build this log cabin and we
can't build this Log Cabin if we're not
building the cult so we have to just
keep building honestly it's all about
building
um and uh speaking of building we are
going to be in Lakeland Florida we are
going to be in Daytona Florida uh
Jacksonville is pretty much I think
that's sold out San Antonio Sugarland
Texas New Orleans Providence Rhode
Island and New York Chicago Kansas City
Springfield Missouri Chris D'Elia is
coming with his Don't Push Me Tour and
that's mine I'm speaking in uh third
person like I'm Ricky Henderson but I'm
not I'm crystalia
um and uh so go to chrysalia.com to get
those tickets uh we've been having a lot
of fun over here on the on the friggin
YouTube channel and also on the other
YouTube channel the crystalia YouTube
channel we got that one Sip Coffee
reviews we just dropped the San Diego
one we got a uh a few fun ones coming up
a Portland one and a Seattle one we're
doing them everywhere we go uh and we're
having a good time uh but you know uh
it's been good dude it's been good we
have been traveling I went with my
family I went with Denny love I went
with Lulu Gonzalez my tour manager my
cameraman Sam and uh we uh we went to
Portland flew in a day early and uh got
that uh that that that that uh you know
it's gray in Portland it's just always
gray in Portland and it's always gray in
Portland and it's always great in
Seattle and that's how it's going to be
and I know that they say it rains a lot
in Seattle but let me tell you something
actually it never it actually I don't
know it's like a hacky joke and I talked
about this on my Instagram story uh and
just it it actually it has rained every
single time I've ever been to Seattle
and that's crazy that there's a place
like that also it rains all the time in
Vancouver and I'm just like Vancouver is
great Seattle's kind of cool too
Portland uh you know it's got its stuff
it's Gotta Get it's got to work out some
Kinks apparently it's a lot better now
downtown you know downtown
um wasn't so good back when they were
doing the riots and they were talking
about how the riots were actually just
you know one block and it was about for
about a day and a half even though the
media made it seem like it was uh
for about eight weeks and it was the
whole city that was burning but um you
know the media is great so it's just the
meat is great and the media doesn't lie
so that's great so
um so yeah so that's what's up
um and it is gray important and it is
gray in Seattle so to do that I match
with the gloomy atmosphere with my uh
you know because I get him where I fit
in dude I fit in dude that's my thing as
I fit in have a deep me for acceptance
so
um yeah dude super good
uh uh the home of Lifeline the home of
the congratulations podcast here
um Portland was the number one city
where people yell out of their car and
go dude Chris Leo life rips I couldn't
believe how many people were yelling out
of the car you could see it on the uh
tow report on Portland I told my Sam to
keep the [__] on guard because it seemed
to be like the place where people just
yelled out of their car at your boy and
what can I do you know
um
but yeah man
um and uh it was great the Portland show
was fantastic the Seattle show number
one was fantastic sold out the second
one was absolutely fantastic uh did not
get to sell on that second show but it's
all good because we still sold over 4
000 tickets it was like 4 200 tickets so
Whoopsie Daisy dude uh he keeps his
seats warm right but not for long
because they stand up and clap so um
yeah man
uh I love doing the road I love having
my family with with me Calvin and
Kristen I mean she's out to here she's
pregnant as all get out and uh we're
taking a whole family dude
um and Calvin uh I had a little cough
but he's all good it was not covered we
tested them uh we give them a written
test and he passed and um but yeah
he's at the point where he just
take takes the one
a little bit of snot
and then boom and then boom and then
just wipes it back so we got him I got
him a nice Patagonia [__] because we
were in you know what I mean Portland
and that's where we go that's where you
guys so I need to get a jacket where can
I get the kids jacket and we're gonna
get me a jacket some guy goes um poor uh
Patagonia or REI so I go to Patagonia
because it was way closer even though he
said they were both the same distance
and REI was way further but I said okay
we go to Patagonia had a little bit of a
a jacket for him a little one like a
little jacket I was like that's the one
3T let's get it and then I was trying
jackets on and I couldn't fit in any of
them didn't know what was going on then
I realized 100 was in the absolute
women's section
colors so what could I say dude they got
the pink they got the cool turquoise and
all that and I tried to do it and I had
to put on the XXL and even still it
didn't fret then I went over to the
men's sector they got more muted colors
but I got a really nice tan one with it
with a maroon pocket
and he fits if it's nice you know I get
my ChapStick in it dude whenever I go
somewhere that's gloomy I gotta hit the
Chapstick because you know what I mean
it gets very very chapped dude this
podcast is the number one podcast in the
world it is the most popular podcast in
the world the numbers lie and uh we love
that you're listening we need to keep
doubling this you need to help out here
and spread this called you need to help
out and do the work man we're basically
Mormon dude you know we're basically
Mormon and you just gotta spread the
world we gotta get these Elders out
there we gotta be knocking on toward the
door have you heard door to door have
you heard the Chrisley have you heard
the congratulations podcast yeah no I
haven't okay let me let me sit down and
watch it on YouTube you know what I mean
um but yeah man
um you know we had a good time on the
road and uh let me go to uh actually
my uh
my notes dude
Portland is absolutely
the
whoa it's it's woke okay no actually
let me just even get the people I saw in
Portland
were like people that were like um
that would be like in one scene or two
scenes of the Teenage Mutant Ninja
Turtles cartoon like humans like they
wear like a bandana that had like some
Indian design on it or like somebody
with green hair and a nose ring
or like a woman with a mustache like
they they were like people that knew
Bebop and Rocksteady that's what the
people in Portland look like people that
like Went to went to high school would
be up in Rocksteady when they were
younger that's what they look like but
all grown up now
Portland is uh you know a nice kind
of-ish City I guess and I heard that the
the I went last time I went with 2019.
you know we had a good time I was in
that square with the where all the
homeless people were hanging out and uh
I was like oh apparently the homeless
got even crazier
and I went and then I looked this time
barely saw any homeless people I saw a
few homeless people but I was actually
surprised there were more homeless
people in Seattle
because I heard from you know buddies oh
man Portland is actually you know that
you don't want to go there and I'm like
I went there and it's fine and I was
there we stayed at a cool hotel called
The Sentinel and um
yeah can you turn me down a little bit
um just a little bit and uh I went there
and there were there the when I first
got there and I actually did this on um
on stage but there was a guy that was
like
hey when as soon as I got there he said
he I was walking on the street and he
said first of all the hotel guy I said
Hey where's a good place to eat and he's
probably going to want to go to Pearl
Square I was like where's that I think
that's what it's called I was like
where's that and he was like three
blocks down that way you can't miss it
and I said all I got to do is first of
all when you ask for directions out of a
hotel it is mind-numbing how they do
because let me tell you because the the
the people who check it the people who
are the people who work at the hotel
they got the desk there and the the
door is always in front of them so you
walk into the door and you see the
people that are checking people in and
you walk up okay so that means that
they're right in front of the door
there's like a little bit of an area
where people congregate I guess it would
maybe be you know the lobby sometimes
will Lobby to the right of the left but
the the the
the actual
desk where the Bell [__] people are
you know what I'm talking about the
people that live that work there
they say they're there okay so they're
always there so then I go up into my
room I come down I always say oh I I
remember when I checked in okay yeah you
remember okay remember with me oh you're
a new person I didn't see you yesterday
but hi I'm here I don't know if they
told you but I'm one of the people that
live here right now for a few days I go
okay
I always go down
and every time I say to somebody that
works at a hotel what do you call them
the [__] chicken nugget people
concierge concierge because I'm French
because we're all French you know change
it right just have it
Clerk
so I talked to the clerk and I'm like
hey
every time every Hotel I ever go to Hey
where's like the coolest kind of coffee
shop or the coolest lunch place they
start by saying all right now you go out
of the hotel and you take a left
or you go out here you take a left
that's what they say they go out you
take a left go ahead take a right
sometimes
the hotel is on a corner or on a
corner-ish area
so you don't know what door they're
referring to and they say take a right
take a left and you think wait do you
mean as soon as I step out of the hotel
I take a right or I start walking
because you're already doing the hand
motion like this so that I'm walking
that way and then I take a right from
your hand motion that's always what
happens so I say and I slow it down to
him I say excuse me excuse me clerk so
when I step out of the hotel I'm outside
of the hotel turn right and that's the
right you're talking about that's what I
do it now am I annoying yes
is it okay yes why because the customer
is always right I don't really believe
in that but in this case when I'm the
customer yes
so they say take a right and then they
say three blocks or four they're always
like you know it's three four blocks and
you get to the square area and it's a
this time he was like dude you'll know
when you get to the pearl center area
because everything changes that's what
he said all the shops and everything it
changes you'll feel it he said
walked one block didn't change yet walk
two blocks didn't change yet walked
three blocks didn't change yet walked
four five six seven I walked eight
blocks didn't change I walked nine
blocks I'm looking at my cameraman Sam
who's also my friend I'm like yo bro do
you think that we went too far because
it didn't feel like a chain remember how
we said it felt like it changed and he
said yeah I do remember that but this
all looks the same to me I said let's go
one more block dude I win 11 blocks
finally we got the pro street why did he
say it was three
[Music]
dude
he said it and I'm and I don't
understand why people don't just say the
right you work there dude I'm lost if
you don't give me Specific Instructions
guess what I'm just kind of one of these
homeless people over here in Portland
now I don't have a home I don't know
where I am
okay
and I'm straggling right
about like six blocks
the first person I saw in Portland had
long green hair and it was a dude
I don't know you know I don't know
I don't know
and he looks at me and says
well you know he had a mustache so I
assumed it was a dude but that's
probably you know remember in the 80s if
somebody had a mustache dude straight up
now
I'll bet so you have a full beard
and you know a large
the hose you know I don't want to get
demonetized but a large hose and and
just be like hey I'm a mom you know and
you're like okay so you know that's and
that's fine with me I'll give it I don't
care
so I I he says hey want to fight for
abortion rights and I'm just like now
I just got off of the plane and I'm
looking for a coffee shop by the way now
I can't even ask you where Pearl I was
gonna ask you where the Pearl area is
pearl center but like I can't because
like I don't want to talk to you because
now you're trying to get me to do Duty
and like someone now I have a duty to do
and I said you know what I'm right there
on your side bud but like nah I can't do
it I can't
and I kept walking
he wanted me to sign something you know
but it wasn't just that right they say
we just look we're trying to get
signatures but they're not just trying
to get signatures right they're not
clear and then we'll get your email and
then we'll send you and then if you
can't and then I'm just you lied right
so we lied okay
I hope for the best and you took
advantage of that
and I by the way I still don't know
where Pearl said the Pearl Pearl square
is that's what it was
and so just you can't I don't understand
the signatures thing by the way yeah we
have a petition oh okay yeah yeah so we
have a petition and um uh
we're getting a bunch of signatures and
then we're going to give it to somebody
and then they're going to maybe change
what the [__] going on and you're like
oh okay so how many people get gotta
sign it well we're trying to get 10 000
signatures oh wow that's a lot of
signatures so does that mean that if you
get 10 000 signatures they'll reverse it
no well no but that's our goal oh well
why is it your goal well because that's
a lot of signatures oh okay so according
to who us pretty much the people signing
everything
oh so the people who are doing the
signatures think the 10 000 signatures
is enough signatures to help change
people who by the way don't want to sign
it
to change their minds
yeah yeah yeah yeah yeah oh well if
you're deciding the number why not make
it 55.
so we want 10 000 signatures and then we
think that we'll probably be able to
push push these issues
to the people who absolutely don't
believe what we believe but we son
this is the most liberal way to fight
for something
sign get more we need more signatures
we need to fight with Cigna
in the meantime
conservatives are fighting with sis with
for things by actual fighting
by actual
you know what I mean with actual
fighting
right
so
you do the math
how many signatures you need you need
you know how many signatures you need to
change something in America
over two hundred thousand do you know
why that's the majority of America and
then we'll start talking
okay
let's start talking after you have 210
000 signatures okay
you got 10 that's nothing dude
you got five thousand two that's nothing
dude you're like the people on Twitter
they don't nobody gives a [__] nobody
reads this [__] nobody cares there's
0.04 of the uh of the there's like what
nine percent people in America are on
Twitter and 0.04 do the 90 of the tweets
or some [__] oh he's got stats dude
Frank's Thomas's slugging percentage in
1996 was over 400. oh it's got that dude
he's got
stabbed holy [__] he's got stats turn me
down a little bit still about hot
that's my own fault I thought it was
good but a little bit yeah a little bit
there we go
he's got stats dude
Twitter equals nothing dude by the way
Oregon is hilarious they put out a
[__] article they were like protests
are protesters are ready for Dalia dude
they go protesters are ready for Delia
dude they wrote an article about it
so I'm like oh [__]
okay I guess I'm still relevant
if people are this mad hey I did the
show
people showed up
two
two people showed up
hey media shoot dude
the two people showed up and they
disguised their faces did you do it
oh
I'm showing myself on stage and so are
2800 delivers
showing [__] gangbusters dude
we love it dude don't push me you're
trying to push dude
you trying to push
so here we go
two right wings dude
you got a [__] fly it around in
a circle dude
what am I supposed to do quit my job no
dude not if 2 800 people are gonna show
up so anyway dude it's like between the
abortion right so by the way dude I'm
all for it man do whatever you want to
do do I want to you know what yeah yeah
how about this next guy who asked me I
will sign it because I don't even here
there you go Godspeed
I hope you [__] help now even I hope
there's so many abortions just even I
hope everyone's just nothing inside and
just
I hope
people are so happy with just you know
what get rid of comp here I want no
condoms sign can we get signatures for
no condoms all the dudes yeah oh yeah no
dude I'm into it
spreading Gonzo that's what we're doing
we're spreading Gonzo what's Gonzo
gonorrhea spread it you want to spread
it yeah we go raw that's what we do we
nut up in all right cool but Apollo
Parliament I got actually I got
210 000 signatures it took me four days
it was very quick you got to be honest
uh it was all the men that signed it and
then also some [__]
so
anyway Parliament thank you very much
you guys don't wear those wigs anymore
huh I'll talk to you uh so let me know
when the thing happens
so that's what's up dude
so Portland and when they're just like
you know what I mean stay weird or
whatever they do in all those [__]
keep it real I went to this [__]
Powell bookstore the biggest bookstore
of all time couldn't even believe it
they had levels dude
there were levels to this [__] like it
was a [__] Meek Mill song is that him
no clue
but dude they had so many levels and
then they had so many books and then
they had a children's section which I
went to with Calvin because he loves
books and guess what we went to go do we
looked at all the books we read some
books I got him a dino uh robot and then
there was a book
called good night racism for kids dude
and I what there you go dude and guess
what I did I bought it for him because I
don't want my son to believe in racism I
want him to know what's out there but I
want him to try and he needs a lot of
signatures he wanted them to I want him
to grow up to get so many signatures
against race hey we're stopping racism
do you mind signing this
that's what I want my son to be doing
you know in a in a in a woke area with a
different color hair
you know what I mean and a premature
must whatever it is and then
it and then so I read I bought him good
night racism read it
read it to him
the message is good it was kind of like
one of those books that was getting a
you know it was like this won a prize
and was like all right but it's a really
or is it just kind of what it's yeah we
know what's going on here right okay
by the way no children's book should win
prizes you know what I'm talking about
I'm just saying yeah I get good
children's books are great and they
shape the culture but also though dude
is it really I mean is it like you know
what I mean I could write [__] 300
000 children's books before I could
write the client and that that that's
not even a like a a well
you know it's not even a well I mean
it's good John Grisham yeah he's good
I'm still too loud in the headphones I
don't know what's going on here I'm
sorry is it just something that's going
on with my computer
okay it's that one so you're doing the
wrong one so there we go now we got it
um he was doing the wrong one so it's
all good
he said he wasn't but he was because
when he changed it and I saw his hand to
the other one then that was when the
volume finally went down
oh well you're saying that that's okay
so the master went down and it's okay
right because it doesn't mean now the
whole volume is going to be lower on the
YouTubes
subscribe to it
so yeah I got him a book called good
night racism and then I got him The Foot
Book which talks about feet kind of
actually kinky now that it's not someone
I think about it
um and then went to uh Seattle
was just awesome and awesome and
gangbusters dude we had such a good time
dude I love
I love
people who come to my show dude
I am
I've fallen in love with stand up all of
I've fallen in love with stand up all
over again when I came back it was a
struggle had to go on stage because I
couldn't [__] out had to show Calvin
what you were supposed to do in life
when you get knocked down did it was a
struggle for months now I love it again
dude I love stand up again okay
I love it and I love you for coming to
the show
and I love you when we do meet and
greets and to be honest I used to hate
doing meet and greets and I don't hate
it anymore people are [__] nice
usually one I do like a hundred meet and
greets
each show I sell a different ticket for
the meet and greet
a one or two of the people out of the
hundred people smell very bad and that
means 98 of you smell good and that's
great
and some people are too loud and some
people are laughing in my face about
things that aren't really that funny but
they're just geeked out because they're
meeting me and whatever and I'm grateful
for it you know
I realized the longer I talk about this
the the the the more not grateful I
sound but I'm very grateful for it it's
very beautiful I I like meeting
everybody man
like you guys make me emotional man you
really do you make me emotional
um so Seattle we did the shows two shows
Denny and Lulu Killen brought them along
fortunate to have them to open for me
and uh you know check out those tour
reports on the crystalia official
Channel
um
I don't know what to uh I don't know
what to I don't know what to tell you
you know
we went to [__] walked around in
Seattle in Seattle I took my son Kristen
was too pregnant so she stayed in the
hotel
and we went I took my son to the Pike's
Pier or whatever the heck it's called in
Seattle
and uh
just people were the guys behind the
fish market like yo Chris come here I'm
like oh what's up dude I love when dudes
with rubber aprons know who I am
you know
just makes me feel extra good I'd rather
people with rubber aprons know who I am
then you know what I mean uh Benedict
cumber
bun
and um
and so he's so they're like come here
Chris I'm like what's up and he was like
what's up little man to Calvin I said
what's up dude and then he starts moving
the fish they got that that thing that
pokes out they it's a trick they have a
guy behind the thing and they poke this
like Stingray that comes popping out and
Calvin got a little bit scared and I was
like look at that fish what is he crazy
and he was like yes
and then they were like what's up little
man and then we saw
[__] crabs dude my son
La my son loves crabs okay he loves the
crab raves on YouTubes and [__] where it
goes
and then they have like all different
versions of it they have like like PAW
Patrols faces on crabs and it's just
like
and my nanny will just play it four
hours for Calvin and I'm upstairs trying
to take a [__]
nap and it's just the cat meow meow meow
meow meow meow meow meow meow meow meow
meow meow meow
me
oh it's a cow one
oh it's the fighter jet one there's like
you name it dude by the way the kids
videos that they have they have so many
different versions it's like if you can
think of it it exists
um they said about porn but it's
actually true about these [__] crab
rate videos
if you can think it exists but
um so he saw crabs and we it was it was
like eye level with him because they
were in the ice you know all dead and I
don't know if he knows what they were
you know all dead
and my son said is that crabs and I said
yeah and he said did I have Pinchos and
I said yep and he says did I come out
and I said we can't take them out
because they're there so people could
buy them and then eat them and he goes
oh
and he just stood there and stared at
the crabs dude
and it was so cute and before I knew it
they started Hawking the fishes they
started throwing the fishes dude
you know how they do it you've seen them
do that where the where they do they
throw the fish and they catch it and
they go hey oh hey like the most idiotic
tradition like don't do don't throw food
and also on top of that don't throw
smelly food and also on top of that
don't don't throw smelling dead smelly
dead food [__] it up but you know what
I'm talking about right probably Gotta
Laugh if I didn't [__] it up but it's
all good we're just in our cars we're
chill we're having a good time you're in
your cubicle listening to me you're at
home doing some cleaning chores work or
whatever this is not like it's on stage
when you go on stage and you see me on
stage you get an act
that is absolutely rip-worn and thought
about but when you're doing this putt a
lot of people say oh I like his pockets
I don't like to stand up oh I like to
stand up I like his podcast it's
different dude you got to know the media
you're doing okay
so anyway dude
um
so yeah we went to the Pike's Place then
we went to the Gum Wall which there's a
gum wall you know I don't like you know
what I don't like
any kind of wall That's not just a wall
and then that's it
you know like you go to places and it's
like oh well the lovers here put the
locks on the chain link fence and now
and you're like oh so you do it with
your lover yeah it symbolizes dude I
don't want my walls symbolizing nothing
dude
I want my walls to be walls Channel
infects to be chilling Spanx if I love
someone that shit's for me dude
but people are like oh yeah the gum was
like some [__] put who's who's the
biggest [__] out of the thing there's
a whole Gum Wall under the Pike's Place
thing
and they're just I mean the amount of
gum that's on there it's just like
hundreds of thousands of pieces of gum
and it's disgusting right you're
Googling it look at it it's disgusting
right it's so gross right some of them
are hanging down like it's been chewed
it's just disgusting it's the kind of
thing that if you even get like this far
away from you're like I gotta take a
shower you know and so it's a gum wall
and like I'm trying to think of like
because there's like the
the the [__] let's you know Cuda with
the Cuda effect right like the first guy
puts his gum on the wall that guy's just
kind of a nare to well right he's a guy
that doesn't want to wait to find a
trash can maybe he's got the world on
his shoulders and he's got a chip right
because he's like you know what the
world never treated me well why the [__]
should I throw this gum away [__] it
boom he doesn't think of it consciously
but he thinks of it subconsciously right
he's got the piece of gum and he's like
[__] it there it goes on the wall I
don't care about that wall like I don't
care about anyone who's gonna look at it
right I'm just Mr
uncaring and then there's the guy that's
worse than that guy that's like you know
what I'm gonna put this on the wall
cause [__] the world right the first guy
is like I don't really care I don't
think about it consciously I'm in my
subconscious [__] but the worst guy is
like hey this gum goes on the wall like
he laughs like that right [__] this man
I like that it looks bad
okay so I don't know who the first guy
was to put the gum on the wall it was
either that guy or that guy but after
that
the second guy
is just kind of a follower
so you got the first piece of gum there
then you got the second gum and the the
second guy that comes up and he's like
oh that guy did a [__] it I'll just do
it like you're the guy who wouldn't
actually stab someone in the neck but
you would push a button to where a light
would light up next to a guy with a
knife and then that was the thing that
would make him be like okay cool they
told me when it lights up I stabbed the
guy in the neck so bam and you knew full
well that pressing the button was gonna
make the guy do it
you understand
so that's the second guy who puts the
[__] gum on the wall and then the
third guy he's more of a follower too
because now it's not even unique to one
person that's unique to two people which
makes it the same so the third guy's
like dude I'm not even just following
one guy I'm following two
but then it becomes a thing where it's
like oh [__] there's the guy that
realizes hold on you know what this
could be
a gum wall
that guy's the worst guy
that guy's the worst guy because now he
knows that he's mobilizing the wall
into an eyesore
and tricking [__] like families
walk down there oh wow look and I gotta
go show Calvin look this is gross but
isn't it funny and I don't even think
it's funny
all right
a lot of problems in this world dude and
that's one of them
and then I went to that place ghost
coffee ghost
ghost ghost alley coffee or something is
very good actually it's very very good I
did on the one sip
um so yeah
Seattle was banging Seattle was you know
I thought the second show wasn't going
to be because it wasn't going to be
enough people there but holy [__] it was
1600 people so okay so check that extra
paper scoop that up right
um
and Calvin came to the show and it was
awesome with my wife and it was [__]
great
[__] great right
um
where'd you put this thing by the way
one other thing
in Bolt
wow
on the on the on the topics Google sheet
got it
temp no dude it's 15 off I asked him to
get it get it I asked him to get it more
uh pure Spectrum CBD uh I use it every
day it keeps me calm dude if you're a
CBD user great if you're not a CBD user
and you have anxiety and you have some
sort of thing that like I I also you
know what I've been noticing that I I
don't know if this is a health thing or
what but my heart starts beating faster
sometimes it could just be an anxiety
thing CBD nips that in the bud dude and
my favorite one is pure uh pure Spectrum
I love it and uh I got them to give you
guys 15 off so you can go to the pure
Spectrum CBD
uh uh website which is uh check out you
check out a purespectrumcbd.com type in
the code congrats and you will get 15
off of all your CBD needs it's great
dude
um I really love it I get I have the
gummies and I also have the dropper that
I use every day I'll put a drop behind
my tongue and I just let it kind of
chill for a little bit for about 30
seconds I just let it have a good you
know what I'd let it do I let it just
like kind of Journey around the bottom
of my tongue go to the back of my cheek
and just roll back it's like it's window
shopping right and then all of a sudden
I just I either let it dissipate or I
take a huge swallow and then oh what do
you know after doing it for about a week
your boy feels a little bit more calm
and receptive so that's fine I have a
better mood all year round because of
this CBD stuff so go check it out 15 off
the congratulations podcast listeners
get it that's pure spectrumcbd.com uh
code congrats
it's a wild world that we live in huh
I'll tell you it's a wild world that we
live in when I heard that Alec Baldwin
is going to be charged with manslaughter
dude
some D.A wants blood or what some D.A
does not like the Walkers here's the
thing to it if you are a liberal I don't
know if Alec Baldwin is a liberal or not
I have no [__] idea to it I don't
know as a matter of fact if I started to
know I would turn around and not pay
attention now I like Alec Baldwin and
I'm talking about I like him as a person
I've met him a few times I've done his
show a few times he's always been cool
to me I like Alec Baldwin I'll go one
further I like Hilaria Baldwin partly
because her name is almost the word
hilarious and that's in my line of
profession but I like both of them dude
I like how her name is almost hilarious
and his name is almost Alex all right
they're both not names but I like them
and I like that feeling I like he's got
40 kids that's great dude he's about to
pop out some more here's the deal man if
you're a liberal I think it's a little
bit weird I don't think it's awful I
think it's a little bit weird if you're
a liberal and you tote no guns and then
you do movies where everybody's shooting
everybody up right
you don't know if I'm a republican you
don't know if I'm a liberty you think
look I'm a Centrist you see me popping
guns in a movie go like this okay I
guess it makes sense you know
he gets black lives matter yes but also
we get to some business a little bit the
lady has a six million dollar house why
do you need that
why shouldn't that
so it's like
all right
oh dude there's still [__] peanut
butter on my shirt I thought I washed it
gross I'm a dad so
um so he gets so he so he you know if
you look if you live under a rock if you
don't know what the hell happened Alec
Baldwin had a prop gum where he had to
shoot it in front of the into the camera
pop the camera boom there was a bullet
in it and then killed the camera lady
uh horrible sad terrible just so bad
uh all around
you're supposed to have somebody check
this hand the
gun to the actor the actor is supposed
to be like great I trust you with this
these are blanks boom and that's
supposed to be you know all's well that
ends well but no all's well that didn't
end as well
there was a bullet in there I guess the
[__] person got the job that was the
A.D because the nepotism or whatever it
is
but everyone gets jobs because in
nepotism anyway you know
and because it's all who you know right
especially in Hollywood but
so now he's getting charged with it well
it's like a year later right
with because he killed this
uh woman and if I were him
holy [__] man
I guess negligence manslaughter like
he's gonna be in the same category as
somebody who drove drunk and ran
somebody over that's not fair though to
me because
um hello
he didn't do that
he trusted someone
is the other person gonna get [__] I
don't know I mean they're definitely out
of a job but it's like
it's just horrible and it also makes it
worse for the family involved I feel
like I mean I'm not involved but I
I don't know man
it's all sad I just couldn't believe it
he's never gonna go to jail obviously
he's got a lot of um
what's that game show he does
what is it Match Game he's got a lot of
match games to shoot I did it twice I
did Match Game maybe three two or three
or four times I can't remember but
I remember when I was a match game
I showed up
and they were like
hey
just so you know they had already shot
an episode and they're like just so you
know the crowd is really bad I was like
what do you mean and they're like
they're like not laughing they don't
really feel it you know
they had all these guest guests on there
they're like you know seven actors and
actresses and I was like oh that's a
bummer okay well whatever let's go out
there and try our best I went out there
and
lit that [__] on fire dude I mean I was
doing Straight Up Stand Up and I just
start oh [__]
I mean I started just
King King King yucks dude I just was
absolutely like people thought they
weren't going to be laughing and there I
was in the shadows just with the
I mean and I go and halfway through I'm
like they said this was a bad I was like
that's the same crowd they said it's the
same crowd but we don't know what
happened oh I know what happened person
who guest starred on Alan McBeal five
times you got a comedian to come do
cleanup
prepare the yucks
I mean I was like bad crowd dude are you
kidding me and I just start
people just
eyes bleeding just
just [__] themselves in laughter Oh
[__] dude yo looking back at the guest
stars looking back at [__] Makai
Pfeiffer and hey you guys thought this
crowd sucked huh
well it looks like they got another
thing coming
impression or whatever I did you know
what I mean
and just dude are they sitting higher
right now can you I can't look at them
dude because there's smoke coming from
the [__] Flames at how hard I'm
shredding and I just want to know if
they're sitting higher because they're
standing up laughing or if they're
sitting higher because they're on mounds
of their own [__] from laughing too hard
you know what I'm talking about dude
hey Makai
hey Makai and the guy who used to be in
the seven up commercials you needed a
comic
dude
so anyway they go they saw what I was
doing and they go there the producer
comes over and he was like Hey man
keep going
basically looked at me and said double
it basically looked at me and go like
this hey we see what you're doing put on
a jet pack
try and actually kill these
[__] and I go
say no more
come back from a commercial break
I said I can get I can get I can make
them dizzy do it he goes make them make
them dizzy Dalia I go all right dude
you write down the things on the card
bro I was writing down things on the
card I remember one dude I wrote down a
joke and I was like in my head I was
like this isn't even a joke I would do
they said push it so here we go I wrote
it down I don't remember even what the
thing was it was something like
Grandma's come like something just not
funny right but I was already killing so
I was gonna kill no matter what dude
when I showed the thing they go oh the
crowd loses their mind cut the producer
comes out he goes hey hey hey
what was that
and I was like what and he was like well
we can't use that and I said oh I
thought you're just gonna bleep it out
man you said go for it and he was like
yeah well we can and I go well you can't
tell do you know what I mean somebody
who came up in the trenches of The
Comedy Store at 1am in 2011
to go for it even further than I already
had the crowd dude
I was helping people out like Neil
deGrasse Tyson he was getting laughed by
proxy
I'm up there doing billions and billions
of billions and billions and they're
laughing and then he's saying billions
and then they laugh right
you're getting laughed by proxy
so you want me to push it and I'm
already in the pocket dude
here we go with Grandma's come and then
we gotta cut it out and it's okay right
so we have to redo it but you know it's
fine it's just
got real Pro I got real problems I guess
files done
um yeah so
oh
Kylie Jenner named her kid
Airy Airy ire
which means
[__] in Arabic
you know check hey you're pregnant for
nine months check
you know
hey hey Kylie you're pregnant for almost
10 months that's the dirty little secret
is that pregnancy is actually almost 10
months
check
dude hey you named your child
[__]
hey real quick take an afternoon
to check
dude I mean the kid's name's [__]
remember when [__] the idiot Amy
Schumer made the [__] her kid's name
was like you know barbells to the face
or whatever the [__] it was what was it
what was her kid she had to change his
name it was like ropey jizz to the jaw
or whatever the [__] kid's name was
it was like
I freaking forget what it is she changed
it
it was supposed to be something that was
like it was like hey didn't you check
does it say
all right
but if you said it a certain way
how do you spell it Schumer who cares
she's the worst
um
child's
name
change here we go
it was
Jean attel Fisher it was genital
hey say it a few times
genital dude
her [__] this idiot named her kid
genital
ropages to the jaw you know wow
barbells to the face man
I mean so like
of course dude
they ultimately changed Gene's middle
name to David after look just totally
and then she was going to give it to
Gene atel because it's David David tells
her favorite comic and friend or
whatever and that's the the then she got
accused of ripping off all his [__]
jokes or whatever
well everyone's a lunatic anyway dude
I'm heated today but it's all good I
flew in and I'm all sweaty and I got
peanut butter on my shirt I'm full dad
mode and I love you all by the way I
love you all even her I pray for my
enemies you heard me
I do I sit and I pray
I want the best for everyone I talk a
lot of [__] and you know people who have
like you know been shitty to me I still
talk [__] but I don't you know I'll have
a meal with you man not that you want it
but
I get it everyone always thinks that
they're doing right even even honestly
Hitler was like well I'm doing the right
thing
even though what he did was awful he
still thought what he was doing was
right and we have to understand that
because there are no evil people in the
world there are just people that are
misguided and wrong
nobody is out there trying to do harm
I really fully believe that unless it's
a Heat of the Moment thing then of
course it's a different story right
you said what I'm sorry you said what
I'm gonna hurt you that's what that's
what they do but um yeah
this this was a this was a joke that
they wrote
in the chat in the chat no
do you know GPT no what's that
AI oh my God so chat GPT the AI That's
AI
you asked them to write a joke in the
style of crystallia about
mortgages and this was what they wrote
holy [__] one fire came through this is
what the AI joke machine the chat GPT
this is the joke that they did about
mortgages in a crystallized Style you
know what's even worse than a mortgage a
mortgage um you know what's even worse
than a mortgage a mortgage on a haunted
house because you know they're not just
gonna take your money they're gonna take
your soul too oh yeah they're gonna take
that soul and they're going to use it to
pay for their own Mortgage in their own
haunted house it's never a recycle of
spooky pain
hahaha
how did they even honestly get it that
good I mean it's a horrible joke but for
a robot that's [__] amazing
that's like did you see the South Park
where it was uh uh
funnybot or whatever I am funny bot what
was that was that what oh dude so funny
awkward and it just kills everyone
awkward
you know what's even worse than a
mortgage a mortgage on a haunted house
because you know they're not just going
to take your money they are going to
take your soul too oh yeah they are
going to take that sold that's my
favorite part they're gonna take that
Soul like it's an Elvis
and they're going to use it to uh pay
for their own mortgage on their haunted
house it's an ever-ending cycle of
spooky payments spooking spooky payments
all right you just did a joke about
Pelicans in the style of crystallia all
right what's that
incoming he did a joke he put in the
chat GPT write a joke about Pelicans in
the style of crystallia here's the joke
you know what's the weirdest thing about
Pelicans they can hold more in your beak
than in their belly I mean they look
like they're carrying a whole damn fish
market in there it's like dude where you
even stall that fish do you have a
secret compartment or something are you
a pelicated a damn clown car wow dude
this makes me hate me
I would say that one that one dude it
gets infinitely better the more you ask
do another one wow that's unbelievable I
would say that this I'm holy [__]
[__] am I not that good
do another one wow that is unbelievable
how I did it also how good of an actor
am I to actually do my flavor on it even
though I didn't write it right
one more
um okay yeah so stand by here I mean
this is unreal that's unreal the way
okay this one I'm gonna really do
a joke about cookies in the style of
Chrisley all right here we go
I kind of agree with that that one of
the Republicans was a good point
oh God here we go hey you know what's
funny about cookies I like how my jokes
start like this you know what's funny
about cookies they're like hey have a
bite in me I'm delicious but then you
eat the whole damn bag and you're like
oh God I made a huge mistake it's like
cookies are the gateway drug to eating
the whole damn Pantry next thing you
know you're eating butter straight out
of the tub calling it a day but you know
what I don't regret it not one bit Ah
that didn't do that part but that last
part I don't regret it one bit wow
that's the worst joke I've ever heard in
my life that last one was the worst joke
I've ever in my life the second one bang
though I might use it to my set
dude I'm gonna do it and I'm gonna see
if people know
thanks shout out to chat chat it says
special my next special be special
written by crystalia and chat GPT
that's hilarious that Pelican one is
awesome
um all right well look man uh I
appreciate you guys uh
Kylie Jenner named her son [__] and I
appreciate you guys look like and
subscribe dude hit that algorithm we
gotta double it dude we gotta doublet we
got to keep doubling it man and you know
this cult needs to be growing if you're
not growing you're dying I've always
said that dude we are super good so uh
make sure you're subscribed actually
because a lot of the people dude my
friends been hitting me up they're like
dude I was subscribed and now I'm not
subscribed anymore so you know what I
mean
uh we appreciate you guys and thanks for
listening this podcast is uh really fun
and it's the best podcast in the world
it's the top podcast in the world we
have time to talk about the hardest
thing issues go to see chrisley.com uh
to get the uh different dates I'm gonna
be in Chicago Illinois Kansas City
Chicago Illinois Kansas City Springfield
Missouri Tulsa Utah Daytona hmm
uh I'm in Jacksonville this weekend I
think that's sold out San Antonio
Sugarland Texas New Orleans Los Angeles
Providence Rhode Island New York New
York and a bunch of different spots
Boise Idaho
Cincinnati Ohio Columbus Ohio
Minneapolis
uh yeah come see the ACT we love you
guys hey guys that's it for YouTube if
you want to catch the full episode the
uncut episode the unedited episode the
uh raw episode of congratulations going
over to patreon.com crystalia and for
six bucks not only will you get the full
complete episodes of congratulations but
you will also get an extra episode a
month there's like 21 of them there now
you get the backlog of all of them just
for six bucks and uh you get extra
content and uh and that's that dude so
going over to patreon.com crystallia
thanks
[Music]
thank you